jordan montgomery this will be his third
start of the year 1-0 here's the one-two
struck him out swinging
another high fast well that was at 94.
2-2
stride three
meadows down looking a strong
one two three inning for jordan
montgomery for the tampa bay rays it's
gonna be right-hander tyler glass now
and it's hard to imagine him being any
better than he has been through his
first three starts
and a cut and a mess
takes care of lemay here that absolute
beautiful curveball there by tyler glass
now and that's what we see an awful lot
of the put away pitch the hook
so good you can throw it right down the
middle of the plate take it to the
bottom and get a swing like that out of
an excellent hitter here's giancarlo
stanton 1-2
grounded shortly and a diving stop by
wendell gets to his feet and fires and
fires it over the head of diaz moving to
third is hicks and reaching at first is
stan yankees have runners on the corners
for gleber torres
and the bases are loaded as torres works
a walk
[Applause]
and here's brett gardner
here we go 2-2 again
and a tapper right side stepping on the
bag as diaz to retire the side francisco
mahia
batting from the right side against
montgomery
he takes the fastball deep into right
field judge will run out of room that
baby's gone
home run on the first pitch francisco
mejia
puts the raise out in front
so two straight walks to open up the
second inning and one away here is
dj
line drive a base hit
into right center field sanchez rounds
third he's coming home the throw comes
into second it's an rbi single for le
mayo and the game is tied at one
and montgomery will face
randy arose arena
this game tied at one and the payoff is
struck him out swinging fastball up
that is strikeout number six
so runner at first and two out it will
leave it for manuel margot
now here's a pinch and margot sends it
into left-center field well tagged and
that one is gone
margot on the first pitch has belted a
home run a two-run shot
his second home run of the year and the
rays take a three to one lead
gary sanchez
is out of the game you can almost see
when he took off his mask i mean his his
right hand is all swollen a tough break
for gary sanchez and the yankees
higashiyoka
is taking over behind the plate
beautiful play by arshella
as he robs wendell of a base hit
phillips a lefty hitter struck out his
first time against montgomery 1-2 is cut
out of miss
phillips strikes out well susan he's
retired eight in a row he's
getting stronger
number seven for montgomery
last now having a little problem with
the glove hand
mike sandoval the raise one of the race
trainers is out there to take a look at
him there's a guy that has a very high
tolerance of he's he's in some serious
discomfort and he is he is remissing in
pain
and you just wonder if it's cramping up
on him it was his final warm-up pitch
where you could see something was
bothering him
and he's yeah he he is cramping my gosh
now they're giving him some electrolytes
and now here's giancarlo stanton
with a runner at first in two outs the
one two on its way
check swing did he go i think he did the
last get first base and he did
and tyler glass glasnow
is able to work through
five innings today
and keep his team in the lead the
yankees are to be very happy with
montgomery i'm sure they are
win or lose and he's pushed a terrific
game he's given up just two hits
he has struck out seven the one one is
popped up
right in back of second who's going to
make the catch
it is glebe taurus to make the catch and
that takes care of the
sixth inning
oh montgomery's push back
there's margo
let's see they can turn two
there's one on to first
got him a double play
turned quickly on the pivot by odor
and
boy it looked like he got there and
of course he got easy easy
one-on-one out here is
francisco
is margo running the pitch is low throw
to second it goes into center field
backed up by odor and a steal of second
from argo
here's joey wendell with a chance to add
to the lead
fly ball back into right field judge is
going to go back looking up and that
baby's gone
home run into the bullpen
home run number two
for joey wendell the two-run shot
and the rays take a five-to-one lead
here's rugnetto door he's over two
the 2-0 swung on hit in the outer right
it is high net as far it is gone
it's the first home run for rookie adore
as a yankee
you are oh derrific if you look at the
way the yankees are gonna have to get
back in this game and you look at this
443 feet and no doubt or they're going
to need some home runs they are just not
stringing together hits
so you're going to need a few long balls
ej lemayo
is one for two with a walk
up the middle and through for a base hit
another multi-hit game for dj lemayo
here is
aaron judge
that one is ripped into right center
field that ball is going to be
in the gap and up against the wall
lamellae is being raged home he will
score it's an rbi double for judge and
the yankees are creeping back in it
they're now down by two
francisco mejia
sharply hit up the left field line past
the diving urchella down into the corner
rosso is going to score the rays do pick
up another run on a double by mejia his
second run bad at end of the game
and the rays make it six to three
still one big out to get against the top
lamehu's so tough but much rather face
him with two out nobody off
two
and he got him
that's going to end at the rays our
winners a strikeout of dj le mayhew
and the rays take game two of this
series
6-3